yellow the software gives me information
that I'm life as usual I have my doubts
that that's really the case so I'm going
to ask you again like every week to give
me a short information if I'm really
life um it's been reliable last couple
of times so I'm optimistic yeah hello to
the people in the twitch channel there's
a question can we challenge you today
hmm sure why not I mean I usually play
in the pool but if you send a challenge
to me I will play the odd game yeah
let's go for a five minute game last
week I tried with some somewhat wacky
openings and this this time I'm going to
play it like I usually do yeah try to
score some points okay i'm playing drop
stone here an international master from
Russia we got the green felt offense
yellow to rot Slav rots love chess I'm
not sure how to pronounce the gem and
welcome yeah greetings to Switzerland
yeah they play that Bishop e6 stuff now
and he probably will know his is booked
moves no I mean okay I'm not saying that
this isn't good just that I never saw
that move coming so maybe Bishop g5 b6
interesting hmm yeah probably just go
before
yeah the video setup reminds me of Star
Wars when they communicate by Holograms
yeah like in Star Wars Episode foyer
with those Holograms popping out of the
robots yeah a bit a little bit like that
okay knight c6 I'm attacking that with
b5 and he jumps to before an interesting
position here the night on a two ok I'm
going to place his six he has night a 2
as a possible idea it's a very
unconventional position never seen
something like that yeah I basically
have to check and now he's got the rook
there he has some one possibility that
he has is to play queen to d6 and
possibly queen to before this is some
really an somewhat annoying idea I think
I probably should try to get rid of that
rook quickly ok he won't be probably via
he probably won't take but this is still
more comfortable in comparison then
allowing Queen d6 before on the other
hand this is not all roses for him I
could have taken e7 but that felt risky
but should be too why have I just want
to develop with 9003 and castles hmm he
wants to play night before that's very
understandable hmm i wonder if i should
take on f6 yeah there's a question will
i ever develop my king side stay tuned
yeah there's a grain of truth to that
maybe I like okay let's take that 94 is
just awfully awfully annoying so I'm
taking it mmm how is the video setup
done it's a question you mean that that
hologram style yeah with a green screen
like they use it form for for TV and and
professional productions I've got a big
green screen behind me so hmm what now
tickets are taking with the a porn now I
don't believe in that let's take it and
now yeah I would like to get to the c7
power that would be nice not easy let's
just castle Bishop b4 probably coming so
there's some way and I can always go
back to have one let's see um any sharp
openings hmm today I'm just playing what
I usually play which means like a
middle-of-the-road stuff I won't play
anything completely bonkers that was a
bit too frustrating last week to be lost
like after move five on the Latvian so
I'm just playing playing normal stuff
yeah this is kind of kind of solid I
know what now 95 I'd like to get in some
kind of activity let's jump in 95 oops
sorry i'm not sure that you will take
what i can play that pre move anyway hmm
i can go Bishop d3 maybe next is there
some possibility to reach um
yeah i think i'll try that tonight to be
49 286 is he going Bishop e7 maybe maybe
I am he plays Bishop e7 that is a good a
good move may I definitely I don't get
the area I don't get don't get to that
pawn to once it's out now he gets the
bishop on CL that's very helpful from
his perspective I mean so yeah I was
thinking g4 might be an idea but that's
not really helping so let's just drop
back I'm shuffling here admittedly not
having any great ideas Bishop d3 mmm now
then the b5 pawn be five point we'll get
week can I go here and Bishop d3 and I'm
really not sure about that hmm very
difficult to find any active idea
I don't really have an idea here in that
position I have to say it is really
passive and one minute 20 will I play
some Bulleit games for my channel
anytime soon hmmmm not sure it's really
it's not for everybody to do commentary
on bullet games and i usually don't feel
like doing that very much Bishop g4 is a
good move yeah the week aged porn but
maybe I can do something and now he's
playing this year yeah he played that
well what can you do you can probably
just take on edge to play that position
and Bishop e2 or something it's tough to
get any play here you can play rook
somewhere I am that sets a good one for
starters not great you probably can just
push the beep on I don't think that age
five is important yeah that's also
possible
happy 3 b3 is just promoting Roxy five
okay and they played that well it wasn't
a good position out of the opening
wonder what was wrong there but um I
really was was in trouble right right
from the start around here thats it's
already a bit uncomfortable even though
blacks maybe maybe I should really take
that that is having porn I wonder ok
anyway let's go for them go for the next
game let's go for Sicilian yeah I mean
okay someone requested sharp openings
I'm going for us the same but I can I
just don't play the dragon or stuff like
that it's not my way of playing what is
that Queen d3 really that looks weird
Wow okay I don't believe this 1 bid so
we can i can send him back their queen
is on g3 funny but it take it makes it
get it get some pressure on on on g7
anyway that should be should be okay at
that position taking on before it's gone
f4 here hmm yeah maybe rob c 8 yeah it's
not so easy to develop that Bishop with
the Queen og three interesting idea
Queen d3 I don't believe it's any good
but ever going to bring back the
bookcase background yeah ask ICC they
they requested the green screen setup
you want the books back just yeah right
to the ICC guys and request the books
it's not it's not wasn't my choice let's
see yeah i still cannot develop that
Bishop which makes me really nervous I
wonder if night h5 night x f4 as an idea
maybe i can do that it's not working
let's go for it yah mo doesn't use the
green screen iya yet he will I'm
basically piloting the green screen
setup yep someone has this resigned
button in the video that's weird okay I
took on f4 for that 'if I've idea I just
wanted to get rid of that annoying
pressure
yes 10 p.m. central european yo that is
10pm right so let's see what about this
i still cannot develop what about
Queenie 725 is that yeah I think I have
to do something like that it looks a bit
awkward but how do I ever get get
development maybe e5 now offer for him
it's an interesting move Queen e5 rookie
won it was a straight away and pawn
takes but okay that position is probably
still fairly solid I hope someone
requests me to make my own twitch
channel I have a twitch channel is just
don't use it I don't have time for
streaming really there should be seven
night c7 check I can't go king d 7 which
is not ideal but walking away it may be
king evade so I can take a sick song so
King d7 maybe really king be some icona
that it's not that bad yeah I think
maybe it's just my unwarranted optimism
but I'm not so sure if this position is
so bad no um it's not the Sicilian con
it's not really to my taste that much
because um it allows some Hedgehog stuff
and I don't like to play their job ah
sorry voice is failing me someone was
chas explain is my hero yeah that's nice
things
so let's see I gained some time here I'd
like to take there and play Bishop f6
but it's not going to work hmm maybe
just here it's a very strange position
yeah green each time it's not Central
Europe in time it's a different
different thing that's a question what I
do recommend to play against the
hillbilly in the caro-kann yeah I happen
to know what that is because mr. Simon
Williams made a video on that just
nonsense that opening play whatever you
want any normal move will suffice just
d5 or whatever it's just nonsense just
take the just don't take the pawns and
you will be fine I mean nonsense is a
bit strong it's just not a very good
opening black should have an easy game
after it yeah f6 is a bit ugly I know
but how to cover that stuff there our
case coming over to g4 hmm ok can I
activate that Bishop a little bit g4 you
should be far from King d8 ugly stuff
ugly stuff Kim da da king eh hmm here
maybe
d6 looks kind of shaky yeah going to see
form still I'm not not seeing how I'm
losing quickly maybe I should have
played a 3am yeah I would do that do
that soon no no no I won't do it
probably but 90 x e6 is not such a big
deal i can still play a 3 or take it and
King c7 isn't that fairly safe rook rook
air-five is coming
okay rook air-five I was planning to
take h2 ok so here I can go Quincy five
but that should that should be ok really
i don't i don't see a big problem here I
could have taken before actually why
didn't I do that but anyway anyway maybe
before start happening I don't know
Queen B 5 mm I take your phone what's
the problem I will take it of course
stupid stuff can go d5 maybe g5 Wow
oh my hell we looked at that says a bit
too much it's too much on d5 what did i
do here awful really awful it was that
was an ok position actually ok what is
he doing here don't get it I don't get
it really I have nine seconds but Luke
takes do you one is the threat wow what
what if what the swindle I'm sorry well
that was very lucky and yeah so let's
say next game someone remarked that Alex
yeah melinski made an icy video about my
favorite Kings Indian line with age
three and Bishop g5 yeah that's true
that line I had recommended a couple of
years ago in an individual series for
white white playing 1d4 llamo at the
time was a huge expert so it's not like
he could he copied from my idea or
something it's the other way around yeah
I sure someone remarks that whiter white
could have won the last game that's for
sure that was just a very cheap swindle
ok so we got um an old Indian IAM
against the Nightlord the Nightlord so
let's go here
someone requests me to play the Kings
gambit no I will play normal stuff now
there's a question and players talk
about according to theory what is better
what does that actually mean hmm yeah
I'm not quite sure what is unclear to
you about it I mean it means that why it
has somewhat somewhat better chances to
gain something suspension or it's a
substantial also it might mean that it
is some easier to play yeah that's also
very different very important thing like
a position might be objectively totally
okay but it's sometimes easier for
particular sites to find the right moves
just a matter of practicality um someone
asked me how do I imagine the chessboard
in over the board games like to do 3d
who cannot tell you I really don't know
really don't know how do I imagine that
mmhmm yeah it's free dimensional I guess
but it's I really never thought about it
okay this position here is very nice as
c5 is a big weakness and he has a hard
time to to cover that i will just attack
it and then pick it up I guess I the
theory part okay what about this theory
mean yeah inlet it just means that um
people have devoted some time to figure
out what the best moves maybe and in
that case we call it theory simply
because it has been um it has been
checked and entered and verified
theoretically meaning not in a game but
in study yeah on over them over the
board with computers or whatever
very often you have to also make a
difference between the theoretical
evaluation of a position and the
practical value in some cases it might
happen that a position is actually very
well valued theoretically that one side
is better but the practical results
speak a different language for example
the Kings Indian defense is a very
typically typical case for that were
quite often white players do have an
advantage through advantage
theoretically speaking because yahoo you
see that objectively chances should be
higher for white but in practical play
like very often succeeds because he has
dangerous counter play someone asked why
was it that yesterday in blitz um
someone be beat people regularly on a
particular day and the next day he
played played worse how does that happen
that's one of the one of the totally
unclear things and chess yeah this is
this weird animal called shape yeah some
some days you're in good shape some days
you're in terrible shape and frankly
nobody knows why why it is like some
days are much better than others if
there would be a clear recipe I think
people would avoid the bad days but it
seems it seems totally unclear I've got
um um I got those days myself I remember
very vividly that last year i was
playing in the german singles blitz
championships for the first time I never
tried to play those single blitz events
over the board in Germany but I tried
and I got to the German championships
and I really felt that on a good day I
can do things I mean not win the event
but but yeah I wouldn't be afraid of
anybody and I played like a complete
complete no words yeah i blundered
pieces and
it was just absolutely awful a little
bit like most of my games look like the
black players games in that in that
particular game yet yeah just getting
outplayed losing pieces and stuff like
that so you have days that are totally
inexplicable yeah and on some days you
are sharp it has some something to do
for sure with how you slept the day
before the night before and end your
nutrition I think that's totally
important but yeah also head to head
good games and days where nothing really
seemed to fit and then I still played
well yeah that's a remark that John
fedorovich also had problems with the
ICC simultaneous display software that's
and cannot really say that's good to
hear because I would like fat to have a
good good time when you place the Samuel
but at least I'm not the only one who
struggles with it I hope that we can do
something until next time to to them to
help that is that that something can be
done to help me play the simul better
there's a common source where so he
asked someone else think you are this is
there a common source where the theory
is documented for all openings the
answer graffiti of chess openings yeah
that's hopelessly outdated and usually
you say it's it's known to theory if it
has been published somewhere or has been
played in a game funny enough it's also
called theory if it has been seen in her
in a game yeah in a practical game so
what happens here hmm yeah that seems
kind of wrong it seems a bit wrong queen
bee three sedums it's probably not maybe
maybe I'd start with capturing
oops one it looks a bit loose black
setup looks rather loose we'll see how
the question can I please explain
tactics you are using in mid game as you
play I can try I can try but it's not
all tactics many moves adjust yeah just
fit in just fit in the position there's
a question what's my opinion on the car
can book by you wanker busca from 2015
yes that's a good book i also got it
just very recently and I assembly I
couldn't yet look at it in a in a very
detailed fashion I want to do a review
on the book but but i didn't manage yet
I simply don't want to do a review
without your having looked at the book
in enough detail so yeah it will be on
my channel but not the other day yeah i
also have been very busy in recent weeks
two or three weeks let's say with with
my own book my own book is is out of
course as I said earlier and I'm
currently busy sending out signed copies
too interested people so I'm basically
going to the post office almost almost
every day and sending out books to two
people that's a very nice experience
getting to know many people were
interested in my book and it's some some
very nice some communications that I got
from that so I'm very thankful for
everybody who ordered ordered ordered
this book um
I will try keto diet to improve
concentration what is Catoe kato diet is
that it's that low cop I'm not quite
sure this is kind of irritating nowadays
with all those some different
nutritional concepts I attend to I tend
to confuse the Franken confuse the
things yes IAM in that cow can book by
um jovanka busca um she plays with short
castles yeah that's uh that's better
than lon castles okay in that game that
I playing currently we've got an
interesting situation um Black has
pushed his pawns there in front of his
King which I'm not quite sure is such a
great idea it's got a weird bishop on b7
and I'm trying to get some attack going
now it's the question how do I get a
signed copy of my book um yeah you
should write a meal to me or send me a
message on the ICC that's also an idea
just get in contact i mean if you google
me you will find ways to contact me and
the just term just try one of the ways
email is the simplest because i will
check it very regularly um and my email
address all so simple it's my first and
last name and then at gmail com I'm
going Bishop d3 habits I'm not sure
about that really and I got he's got
this doubling on the default on the F
file which can be dangerous even though
is playing without that Bishop it's
still not so easy maybe the sugar three
known for c6 and capturing ok someone
just informed me that the keto diet is
no cops at all who no cops no cops is
difficult for me lo lo I can do and I
try um but no it's difficult ok he
probably has 95 that's a it's a weird
that's a weird situation ok I have to go
g4 keep that to keep that fr closed it's
a weird situation blacks position looks
strange to me but I don't have a clear
way of exploiting it is g fiber move
then each form hmm I think I can play
that if I get an H for that's totally
fine yeah someone says I don't trust
these diets um I'm too honest I also
don't if you if you just do it in a min
in a way to to do it too harshly um it
doesn't it doesn't make any sense but to
avoid an unnecessary totally unnecessary
cabo hydrates i think is a very very
useful thing especially a avoiding sugar
i'm trying that now I'd already lost
quite some weight but it's a long road
so it's a nice position h5 will come
it's a very very very good position now
so yes someone I think I got a copy of
my book in Amazon but that's not yet the
date of expedition yeah the thing is
that they are not that many books on
Amazon that they ordered or that you can
order it seems and they're out of stock
they are out of stock pretty quickly a
little bit like black hairs out of ideas
against those pawns so let's get going
with the new game
someone asked me is it possible to
challenge you and watching the stream
yes you can do that that's the question
if you had a lot of success with poker
like making 120 thousand euro a month
would you have quit chess mmm ok a month
a month yes I guess I would 100,000
120,000 euro a year no I don't think so
100 thousands 100,000 120,000 euro a
year yeah that's nice it's nice to have
but you know if you if you if you are
like 60 or 70 or 120 it means that you
don't have to have to worry much about
money I don't for me it's not a huge
difference if you run 120 or 60 or 70 or
whatever and just be okay yeah someone
wanted to challenge me but it said
unavailable i understand i have this
variable set and and i have to unset
that somehow but i don't know how it is
done here actually in that software so
that's a that's a willow pass and they
played the late Bishop takes six the
delayed Bishop takes c6 that's a very
solid line then white players play quite
frequently I wonder if that was right i
think i have to play em I have to start
with the other move anyway there's a
question do i play on chest calm if yes
I know what nickname that's easy my
nickname on chess.com is also just
explained but I am I don't I don't play
that often someone says if I earned one
hundred twenty thousand euros a year you
could afford to play some chess for fun
yes well when I was still working at
at the bank I mean 120,000 it wasn't but
it was fair enough and um gallant anyway
I still didn't quit chess a plate and
studied what I what I wanted to do and
now I'm it's a bit different but it's
totally cool so let's see he's trying to
do something on the dark squares my dark
squares a week yeah I think I should try
to get rid of that someone asked me if I
play more computer for impossible games
on chess.com well this is an icc
streamer you know um I'm not really i
mean i have played those ones in a while
but it is not very interesting in the
long run to play against the engine and
this applies this is not not dependent
on chess.com or any other platform
playing against an engine is never
really fun so I don't I don't do it do
it regularly anyway yeah and talking
about not much fun this position is also
not fun can I get rid of one look I mean
I don't really think that so much is
happening here but it's damned
uncomfortable I Bishop Bishop d8 he
didn't see that that's lucky
okay I mean he will retreat rooks one
look whoa really that's surprising with
one look traded it should be really
harmless someone asking if they are
chess bars in the place where I live no
I won't find many in general what's the
best person you've ever faced Eliza's
you mean the highest rated the strongest
player um oh I played a couple of very
strong guys I played my camera a couple
of times kawana raja baath i also play
cars when he was a little kid but in
recent times kara wanna enter Nakamura
mm yeah greetings back to osnabrück this
is not i mean it's it's far away from my
place but relatively speaking not so far
away yeah my opponent is mostly
shuffling has not much to do i can i can
offer him a drawer there maybe it takes
it yeah it takes it it's very boring
okay that was a bit unfortunate very
boring position my question what's my
opinion or a question what's my opinion
about the night off yeah great opening
yeah one of the best that you can play
if you like the Sicilian like a sharp
fight let's um let's do them and then
spray the night off why not I can I can
do that actually I'm on the road it was
a bit of a Freudian behavior here for
talking about the night off I just I
played it so there's a question what do
I think of Nick last video series on
chest 24 about the news oh and bowganian
yeah Nicholas who should make one must I
wish invited a video series for that for
that server and yeah it's okay um he
chose a couple of lines that I actually
um then I also in the book yeah um and
it's quite was quite funny to see here a
lot of Bishop takes his six I see it now
yeah he can take on his six now
yes Wow it said lost already what is
stupid move here that's really not great
night f 595 can I survive that I don't
think so not against good play hmm Wow
it's got 95 coming wow what a bad
position so okay let's take them and see
green age 510 just complete rubbish what
can you do what do I think of like of
players that always play the same
opening um it's you can it's an approach
I mean um I think it's a good idea to
know some openings quite well and play
them in some gays in some games when
most games let's say to really have
something that you can rely upon
something that you really know not just
like have some vague knowledge that
makes sense but never never deviate from
those openings simply makes you
predictable which is a problem on a
higher level and it also is not much fun
yeah if you play the same stuff really
every game hmm yeah so my recommendation
is usually this is also what I tell my
students and an approach that I like
learn a couple of good lines that show
that you know really know afterwards so
you have something that you can trust
that you can depend upon but branch out
from that so in some single games play
something else where you see okay let's
say you know your opponent plays the
same defense every time then that's a
good idea to maybe test them in that
there's a question what do I think about
Sam Collins books to be honest i don't
think i have one book of him of his i
have i don't know i think i think maybe
i saw video or something that he made
but
but i'm not totally totally sure okay so
what are you doing now after this move
it's very crude but it's checkmate on
between hmm
somehow I think I saw something that mr.
Collins did but I can't remember so if I
take a for it takes e7 that something
else there 92 is probably rubbish I
probably have to check there's a
question if I would do do a commentary
with Nicholas ocean bit in the future
yeah maybe I will as I said maybe I will
but it's not very high on the list of
things to do most me not that is not
meant in an unfriendly way it just that
when it comes to my channel I want to
start to produce some more yeah more
instructional content and this was
falling a bit short in recent times
there's a question about the Carroll
County ugh mmm now I mean you can learn
some lines from the book but it's not
the main thing study complete games of
the caricom let's say learn the middle
games what the ideas are what kind of
plants are good and what kinds of plans
are not good and this will help you to
improve as an overall player not
learning lines by heart okay that's a
sharp position and I'm just um just hope
the best yeah not really carrying much
one important point is making has moved
already i cannot castle long would be
nice sometimes any news about the widow
pest did i find a new line um pool I'm
dabbling around with various things but
currently i'm experimenting a bit with a
sicilian my plan here was rook c8 Bishop
b5 then it's not possible if you take
root g6 I Roxy three
tactics not sure of their work but look
interesting o be three okay I can take
age who here right or not don't see why
not okay queen bee three I don't know
why it seems to fall apart a little bit
yet isn't him I guess mine on night of
knowledge at the end wasn't a huge
problem I mean I was well had a lost
position but it worked out all right so
what now um yes many fine-looking moves
queen of three maybe is there something
that wins 93 route III is not so great
maybe this move do I know any books
which shows the Marshall gambit in the
key q GD or at least something that
shows some plans what is the Marshall
gambit in the queue Judy there's a
marshal variation which is not very good
um I'm not sure if you mean that in the
triangle yeah there's a book by Ruslan
share back off that's the best book on
that line very good book okay i played
this but I not sure maybe he can I can
actually take I can take that pawn on b7
huh oh yes are awful awful okay let's
kill 97 again
maybe he's blundering the Queen since we
had read maneuver I had to cover that
rock though let's see where i can get
the Queen's of them yep I was able to do
that so cover here and go from go from
this position it's got six seconds left
that sets useful um okay yeah that's not
really enough to win but the time
someone someone someone asked me to
pronounce the word ravening the ravening
i am not really good at it I cannot
really do it like a Dutchman um do you
like the time enough more than the
Kalashnikov um that's not the problem
ready I like the Kalashnikov variation
but there's a Bishop b5 and after e62 is
six days no Bishop b5 okay when can we
expect some big tournament coverage and
when do you plan playing eternal
yourself next big tournament coverage on
my channel and on the ISS see will be
the sink filled cup and I'm not
completely sure it should be in a couple
of days actually like maybe like 10 days
or something um you can certainly look
it up it's not not far off and
me playing a tournament I don't have a
classical time controlled tournament
plant in in this in this year but but
I'm trying I'm trying to to play the
world rapid and Blitzen Berlin Raven Ian
hi everything yeah if I would practice
I'm no not right but I can I can
probably do it in an okay way what about
the Goering gambit is that good or bad
would you play it no I wouldn't play
that and it's not that it is
particularly bad just very unpromising
and if black knows his stuff he will
learn equalize very very easily so let
me think about this what is my opponent
doing here is pushing pawns forward here
ok let's go ahead from do you when do
you do I think that causal will win the
sink world cup after the worst
tournament at Norway chess um he's got
good chances sure he's the best player
in the world so why shouldn't he shouldn
t win that event that's a question about
the ravening and pronunciation no that's
no real s and there it's just I think
cannot do it not not well okay 95 that's
a funky move let's take it and see what
I can do now um how to play here yeah I
guess you for should be right there's a
question how much materially would you
say the queen is worth in an equal
position that's no question I'm sorry
because um every position is different
and especially considering such a huge
material imbalance it's impossible to
say there's a question what might cause
an earn in a year um I think there was
some kind of article about that it's not
bad it's certainly a quite above 11
million dollars a year but it certainly
depends if there's a world championship
match and so on yeah that's a very
strange position both King positions are
somewhat wacky there is an S sound
scribbling scribbling maybe it's their
good money for the author in writing a
chess book do we do I get paid by copy
sword it depends on the contract i guess
most contracts have some sort of flat
fee that you earn regardless of how many
copies are sold and then you get an
additional bonus if you get above a
certain number it's um it's not a great
way to hit to make a living too to
really focus on writing chess books but
it was a good experience to to write
that book I have to say okay I don't
know rook e1 s maybe a bit dicey
implanted very in a very relaxed fashion
can i play 95-year or something he's
attacking that look on f1
huh how weird is that the question if
there's a good opening book with a good
repertoire for white was Knight f3 um
there's no real complete book there are
books that have parts parts of this this
kind of repertoire but not not a
complete one so I'm wondering still
cannot really sacrificed of here we
should be three years coming maybe yeah
I'm probably I'm in bad shape here but
it's very difficult to tell what's there
a lot of copies of my book sold um I
don't know I have no information but
what I heard is that the German
retailers um sorta fairmount so at least
clearly more than of some other books
that are comparable so when I'm okay
with that
any good book that you know of in the
Catalan hmm there are a couple of
Catalan books there's one by Victor
Borge on um this also the recent book by
Rho what the heck I cannot take f5 yes
that's a GF I'd because of Queen takes
d4 still I don't believe in that move
here what is that what is the actual
threat he still put something on III or
what I have no idea let's play I don't
even don't know how many copies of my
book where were printed that's the
question can someone buy a kind writing
a single chess book sure there are cars
that are pretty cheap but we will not
talking about we are not talking about
something right there are no Porsches no
Maseratis stuff like that and I mean
even my car's out of the picture the
second Catalan books would be Boris a
broke the Israeli theoretician in our
lives in the United States he changed
occasion so and b6 haha i don't know i
don't know that looks a bit flashy but
can i play some crazy house games next
monday maybe it's funny
um yeah but I win I win two pieces here
and I went on time that one and the rook
flower yep I won that one yeah I think
I'm faring better with my buddy Bob will
openings ok let's go for one more game
we are closer to the end of the stream
um there are many many questions so I
probably missed a couple but I try my
best everyone should do a Catalan book
hmm glad they haven't done reason one
recently maybe I'm not quite sure the
question do i watch chest videos for
study yes I do instead for example I
will definitely watch what llamo has to
say about them h3 Bishop g5 line yes
have to take in the Kings Indian I mean
I will definitely watch that you can buy
some all to you too corolla that we will
be better than many newer cars and not
that expensive mmm probably toyota
corolla has the reputation of being very
reliable but probably not the car that i
have that i would like to drive much
like to have at least some horsepower
some fun while driving is certainly not
a bad idea in my book is someone asking
whether I be playing this chess calm
streamers challenge yes I will it looks
like it that I can manage that
date and time and the correct I don't
like reliable cars yeah I do but I still
like like to have some fun while i drive
drive them otherwise sir I wouldn't so
let's see yeah I'm playing this very
very relaxed fashion you're not paying
much attention so um yeah here we go g4
yeah I'm trying to do something on the
long diagonal and h3 is the next move if
he is not doing something here I don't
know what you should do it looks pretty
awful actually hi Scott c6 coming I
wonder I can just take f3 let's do that
there are a couple of funky ideas pawn
takes rook GA check King and I on the
side and then 94 is shocking no yeah
lamborghini you know I wouldn't even
want one because he would simply cannot
sit in those cars it's just far too rafa
student too damn near the near the near
the near the road it's totally
uncomfortable I never drove one but just
looking at it makes me gives me some
some pain Queen g5 and wide resigns how
do you cover g2 mate how do you cover
that checkmate buddy mr. Frederico from
Brazil that reminds me a bit of a
certain soccer game last year mm-hmm
yeah that would be like Germany 5 Brazil
0 that position so we resigned yeah one
more game that was a short one right
let's go one more and I have a good good
run there gsv see well thats sick rating
there who is that Guillermo see busty on
Vasquez Coleman okay paraguay out i
always think that this is some slavek
flag but it's paraguay yeah someone is
talking about Lamborghini Gallardo's fun
yeah someone wants the trophy wife that
comes with the expensive car and not the
car okay okay I'm just let let's just
think for a moment here I think Bishop
f4 is good am ia fan of classical music
um I like it but I'm no expert I really
have no expert so um I have them the
autumn concert and and operate humans in
my in my itunes library but i really
have no particular idea kind of an
interested amateur um and Carolee what
is this i can win that porn right there
is no big point there right or does he
have something great here night before i
don't really get that so
Bishop g2 rach gia one looks like
suicidal wow what you must be kidding me
I don't believe this one bit Bishop f4
or and then it's got age 60 or Bishop b5
maybe we should be 59 c 6-r you can't
have an sc one or just f4 I can take you
three then that is in fact it is a bit
complicated still I can let let's start
with this move it's not so is it is this
site it just looks like utter rubbish
like every move should win but that's
probably not the case can you focus on
winning this game I don't know if I can
I can try so I would like to get in
Bishop b5 that would be most promising
okay I'm getting out of this Bishop f5
se4 so I don't mind this that much
Bishop cheeks still still every 40 what
is he doing I am ok so i have to go here
and hope I'm not getting checkmated
interesting Queenie 5 is some it is in
down but yeah Queenie five her to create
Queens he will get lots of material bag
I wonder if if you really threaten
something here or not forgive go queen
g2 it takes f form so we will probably
win a pawn or so in the process here hmm
okay let's cover that for the moment
maybe I'm overlooking something that's
easily possible such a weird position
I'm not on the GFL anymore i have to
take that into account the ibook takes
the 78 critics effort check I saw that
move but he could take F always check he
has a couple of flashy moves that one
okay for Bishop e3
i 94 swell
it's can I can check he has got queen to
d6 check which I over looked awful queen
to d6 check now I didn't see that he has
to check on d6 after which I really have
no no particularly good move or any move
for that matter i have only have this
one which is which which will be losing
in the long run yeah that's a shame that
was a completely arm yeah awful position
for black in the beginning but he played
well after that the people with that
rating they usually can do something
right I mean they sometimes play utter
rubbish but then they at one point sort
of recognize that and then start to play
well Bishop cheeks there I can try a
little bit here what is this actually
it's a rook against two pieces so he
still has some some chance you can still
screw it up somehow the same is of
course a true for me here I can easily
blunder more stuff but that rook well
it's not so clear this position why am I
so negative here
the rook on the 7th is very much a
problem then so I cannot go look you one
I can take I cannot rookie one as I
think I should try to use this and no we
can just take that ah ok the position
was still quite interesting because of
the active rook so I have to resign that
one but it was a good session at one nun
i won a couple of nice games interesting
games then we've got we got many good
interesting questions and that's a
question who you think will win the
stream is challenged not clear as I
think the field is probably still quite
fluent um yeah just network never who
play that that's kind of kind of clear
but yeah you never know you never know
who's going to win it Eric handsome is
probably one of the favorites but I
think maxime drugih is also going to
place also a very good blitz player you
never know you never know it's a form
it's a matter of how you fare on that on
that given day I would be very surprised
if I would win it but I hope I can get
in some some cool games um okay so guys
thanks for watching I hope you had a
good time and i'll be back next week
next Monday for a new stream thanks for
watching guys